sin duda alguna la pregunta no era si
ella iba a renunciar sino cuando y con
mucho humor aquí uno de los periódicos
había ha puesto un vídeo de una lechuga
durará más la lechuga que Pues ha durado
más la lechuga
se espera ahora que ayer era mi gente es
el nuevo ministro de finanzas presentes
de su reforma fiscal para el 31 de
octubre tres días después de la elección
del nuevo premiere con estos plazos no
se avecina ya una nueva tormenta
sin duda alguna los nombres que ya están
circulando como posibles reemplazos del
is strolls incluyen a penny mordon que
una ministra Con
escasa experiencia y no una muy buena
experiencia Brandon Lewis el actual
Secretario de irla para Irlanda del
Norte aún con menores experiencia y
finalmente el regreso de Boris Johnson Y
ante esa posibilidad el líder de la
oposición quiere estarme junto a los
demás partidos y a las organizaciones
sociales los sindicatos han reaccionado
pidiendo que de inmediato haya
elecciones generales precisamente
hablando en el tema de Johnson fue una
propia encuesta de los conserva en donde
se vio que la mayoría de los miembros de
este partido respaldaban El regreso del
mismo Johnson
es cierto hay un porcentaje considerable
de miembros del partido y también de
miembros del grupo parlamentario
que apoyan la posibilidad del regreso de
Boris Johnson ahora bien
ya hemos asistido a una al resultado de
una atención entre la membresía del
partido conservador y la mayoría de los
parlamentarios elegidos estos últimos no
querían alistros si los primeros habrá
que ver si esa tensión se renueva Y por
supuesto va a ser muy difícil
establecer una nueva legitimidad para
Boris Johnson dada su
impocularidad general entonces es esto
un panorama muy favorable para la
oposición laborista de Cara a las
elecciones que está previsto que se
celebren en los próximos dos años
sin duda alguna es darle pensar que las
elecciones van a ocurrir antes de que se
cumpla el periodo legislativo es decir
antes de los dos años a los que te
acabas de referir y no cabe duda alguna
de que el ambiente actual Es favorable
para el partido laborista el partido
laborista ha sido muy cauteloso no
conocemos en realidad
mucho acerca de sus propuestas pero el
líder de la oposición ha dicho que tiene
un manifiesto y que está su equipo listo
para presentarse a elecciones sería
difícil pensar en otra forma de sortear
las enormes dificultades políticas tanto
como económicas que enfrentan este
momento el país